this is uh NBC news reporting you want
to pull pull that one up there you go
Trump will announce Trump has continued
to falsely assert that he won the 2020
election but that he was denied office
by rampant fraud if I'm sorry I'm kind
of I'm going to say this right away if
Donald Trump launches his 2024 campaign
announcement off of 2022 complaints
about fraud I think he's going to spiral
Crash and Burn I know a lot of people
have people have reached out to me and
said Tim if Trump doesn't address this
stuff it won't get resolved and that may
be
but um I think that it is too esoteric
and it is confusing for younger voters I
think it is it isn't Trump's Revenge
Trump's retribution Trump 2020 is not
the message we need I think Trump needs
to come out and say Biden screwed you
over and you all know it let me fix it
yeah I mean the American people are
going through a lot of problems right
now especially financially especially
when it comes to our foreign policy
especially when it comes to having a
leader that can't even read his own
notes at the G20 and has to go take a
nap and not meet with the foreign
delegations uh that are meeting at this
prestigious dinner not prestigious but
you know what I mean here uh if he's
going to be smart here he's going to be
talking about America's problems how he
could solve it the future how his
presidency would look like how he would
be different than he was before but if
he does focus on the past I do think
he's going to be losing a lot of people
the independent is reporting that he's
trying to convince Ivanka and Jared to
join him on this announcement so it's
going to be interesting to see who
stands behind him who's there Candace
Owens made some very interesting
statements a couple days ago so saying
that Trump now has someone around him
that's trying to push away the populist
based trying to push away Candace
herself away from Donald Trump so it's
going to be interesting who's there what
he's going to be saying and essentially
what are going to be his plans hopefully
that he's going to be talking about and
not talking about the past yeah I agree
I think if he's going to come out and
complain about his feelings about what
happened to him in his election and the
processes and everything he needs to
display a solution immediately he needs
to come out and say this will help us
prevent this from happening again these
free software systems for instance
voting online on a blockchain for
instance things that are transparent
voting online on like nine different
blockchains so they can all be
referenced but I have a feeling he's
going to come out and complain and not
offer any solutions and just get the the
angry people behind him again like he
did last and if he if he's really smart
he's going to be talking about ballot
harvesting he's going to be talking
about mail-in ballots and also talking
about a plan to deal with all of that
along with big Tech social media
censorship which stands in the way of
Republicans ever winning any kind of
political office well look I mean people
I think I think the biggest mistake that
people on the other side of the election
Integrity issue have made is whether
whether they believe the assertions or
not they have totally ignored the
concerns that people have right
regardless of whether the route is is
true or not what they've done is instead
of saying look I get you have concerns
and this voting issue is sort of the
Cornerstone of a constitutional republic
and so we need to we need to do
everything we can to shore this up right
we go back to the Defcon report from
2019 we're at where they had voting
Village they were able to hack all those
machines right but no one ever addresses
concerns Defcon the hacker convention
right the hacker convention right so
they showed that electronic voting
machines are susceptible and so instead
of addressing those issues and saying
okay look we get it every machine and
voter in the voter Village got hacked
what they did was they decided to
marginalize and essentially tell people
look if you have any concerns about this
you're just a whack job conspiracy
theorist and so you know is that a
running issue for Trump I don't think so
it's always got to be about you know for
most people about the economy well it
has those those issues do have to be
addressed it is one I think what we saw
in the midterms Republicans tried really
hard for the most part to focus on what
the Democrats were doing wrong and
things they didn't like or things they
wanted to get rid of CRT in schools was
a big issue probably because people saw
young can succeed
but I if if you're going after the fraud
narrative
you are not explaining to people what
you want to do other than we were done
wrong and we want the system to correct
that that Injustice
and if you're coming out and just saying
hey we're going to show up our energy
policy we're going to lower you know
interest rates or whatever we're going
to make the economy better then you're
ignoring another big problem so it's
kind of a double-edged sword ballot
harvesting is a major issue Republicans
thought they could they could Target
Target you know political and cultural
issues and that would get them a victory
without realizing the ballot harvesting
operation is intense that ballot
harvesting not fraud there is some
fraudulent ballot harvesting but in 39
States they're allowed to do it I
believe 13 states have no restrictions
whatsoever and we've even heard some
officials say that you can Harvest as
many votes as you want so long as that
person signs off that you are designated
to do so and so that is a major
disadvantage if Republicans aren't
tackling that and and focusing on either
building a ballot harvesting operation
like Democrats have then they're going
to lose if you campaign on that people
are going to say I don't know what
you're talking about so it's it's it's
difficult I understand that you know
Republicans need is a vote by drone
campaign where you designate a drone as
your Harvester it comes to your house
picks it up because no one can has the
time to drive for six hours a day from
from giant farm to giant farm we just
need drones doing it well look it's
here's the we could talk about the the
election Integrity issues and that's
obviously a big concern down in Texas I
mean we're we're all over that we're
we're still dealing right now in Harris
County largest county in Texas most
populous County in Texas uh dealing with
just an absolute abortion of an election
day right I mean we've been joking and
calling it East Maricopa County
um so you know I mean it's it's been
it's been horrible uh but you know if
we're talking about issues that are
going to motivate voters I mean I just
look look at what's motivated our base
right what has led the text at issue to
become to become the issue for 66
percent of likely voters right if Texas
was on the ballot tomorrow 66 percent of
likely voters in Texas would vote in
Texas would vote in favor and the
reasons are pretty clear number one they
believe the federal government is too
big too bloated Federal overreach right
too intrusive in their lives and and
it's the border and immigration for 15
years the border and immigration
together as an issue have polled as the
number one concern for Texas voters uh
when we see the same number of illegal
immigrants cross the border from Mexico
into Texas every month that's higher
than the number of Allied troops that
landed on the beaches of Normandy at
D-Day that is massive and and it goes
unresolved and unaddressed and so uh if
you're going to have uh look if Donald
Trump wanted to make some fans tonight
he would come out and say I'm running
for president and what I'm going to do
my number one issue is to put it on the
ballot for every state to determine
whether they want to stay in the union
or not oh geez
I thought you were going to say he was
going to come out and say build the wall
well yeah I mean maybe between you know
it was funny I was interviewed by the
New York Times one time they said do you
think that uh do you think that the
United States ought to put troops on the
river and we said absolutely let's put
them all along the Red River because
we're tired of the snowbirds coming in
the winter
um geography less than the red rivers
between us and Oklahoma so that's
another story
yeah sorry guys I think it's also fair
to ask is Donald Trump going to be
successful here here is he going to win
because he's facing off against Biden
who who's weak but again is he going to
deal with the mail-in ballots ballot
harvesting is he going to be attacked by
The Establishment is the doj still going
to be going after him the Washington
Post is reporting right now that the doj
is saying that if Trump runs this is not
going to stop the justice department
criminal probe of Donald Trump so if the
justice department goes after him I see
that actually lifting him up and
actually helping him especially when it
comes to the popularity and if he's
running against a Nikki Haley a Mike
Pompeo or Mike Pence all the the Goblins
of the DC swamp that he helped enable
then I see something that's going to be
successful here if he runs against Ron
DeSantis it's going to be a tough battle
it's not going to be an easy one it's
not going to be a tough battle
necessarily one way the way I look at it
is Ron DeSantis and Trump in a primary
will be the best possible thing for
republic applicants and whatever the
more liberty-minded faction is because
Trump will have to find a way to contend
with desantis's popularity and success
policy wise and DeSantis will have to
find a way to overcome Donald Trump's
gravitas his imposing figure his quick
wit
that primary is going to make both of
them very very good and whoever can't
win it doesn't deserve to win it if
Trump goes in there and just crushes to
santus and policy becomes completely
irrelevant then it deserves to if you
can't convince people to vote on the
merits then you don't deserve to be the
nominee so but if DeSantis comes in and
says Bing Bang Boom here's what I've
done and it resonates with people and
Trump is unable to counter that then
Trump doesn't deserve to take it what
about Carrie Lake you guys think she's
going to run for president no because
she just she Heidi Hobbs was overseeing
the election in Arizona won the election
uh so now Kerry Lake lost the election
yeah but she's not in office she's not
in politics she's famous though and
she's well liked I don't think it would
be good if she ran just not good for
them people are going to be sorry yeah
people are going to say if she can't win
a state election what makes her what
makes her think that she could travel
Trump wasn't a politician before he won
yeah but but Trump's Trump was massively
famous though it's true it's true but
but you know I guess we can see I just
don't like the idea of these people who
lose elections just trying to up their
elections like Beto yeah
that sounds very familiar to me I I
think if Kerry Lake if uh she should
fight 110 I believe that everybody
should be protesting peacefully in
Arizona there's 1.3 1.2 million people
voted for all 1.2 million should be out
in the streets especially in Maricopa
just because the the the busted up
voting machines disenfranchised people
and you don't even know who left the
lines who went home because of because
of the failure of the voting process and
that benefits Democrats so I will stress
this
the difference between fraud and
impropriety the different so fraud is
initially the narrative was voting
machines stealing votes
um people forging ballots and things
like that now it seems like people
people are saying the fraud narrative is
ballot harvesting and um voting machines
breaking and I'm like okay well that's a
different conversation if the voting
machines are just garbage and can't
adequately handle the the amount of
people that are coming in to vote then
Democrats are winning because they do
the early mail-in votes if the issue is
ballot harvesting and it's legal in
these states then Democrats are winning
because they have found a way to just
get the numbers and it's a horrifying
Prospect it doesn't matter anymore to
win the hearts and minds of the people
it matters to convince someone who's not
paying attention to sign their name to a
piece of paper and then you leave and
they don't even know what it was about I
was looking at that's scary Katie Hobbs
uh Wikipedia page and one of the last
sentences in the 2022 gubernatorial
election section is that Hobbes decided
not to debate the Republic looking
nominee Kerry Lake to deny Lake a
platform to spread election denialism
you deny a candidate a chance to speak
is that not a form of election denialism
it's not the same thing it's not the
same thing but what a weird sentence
yeah she denied Carrie an opportunity
because she was going to deny something
let me let me tell you real quick what
was what was Katie hobb's role in the in
the Arizona election exactly because
I've heard she's in charge of it I just
want to be clear what was her role
Secretary of State she was the Secretary
of State of her own elections herself
yes so was Brian Campbell I just got to
make an excuse either a deal it doesn't
Excuse excuse either of them but I'm
seeing so many people come out and being
like I can't believe something like this
would happen and it's like yeah and
Brian Kemp did the same but how is it
legal and we said it shouldn't have
happened then and it shouldn't be
happening now but uh the system is just
as just ridiculous stupid broken system
so so it's it's annoyingly frustrating
and no you're right maybe it should not
be allowed it shouldn't have been
allowed back then it shouldn't be
allowed now I'm going to leave it to the
global superpower to screw up the fact
that you should write on a piece of
paper and put it in a box and then count
how many pieces of paper in that box
have the same thing written on it right
I mean we've we've thrown in we've
decided to computerize our our elections
we've made them all electronic
completely ignoring the fact that you
have all the technical experts Who come
out and say anything you know all of
these machines are susceptible right and
and so here we are we've over
complicated A system that you know we
could trace back to uh you know athene
Athens Greece centuries ago you know 2
000 years ago plus three thousand years
you know we're looking at the Athenians
perfected this sort of system where they
would even write on a Shard of pottery
right but here we are we've over
complicated it in allegedly in the
world's only less superpower Still
Standing uh where this is supposed to be
the The Benchmark of of uh civilization
right Democratic civilization we figured
out a way to screw it up up or at least
the bureaucrats here's what I want to
see I want to see Donald Trump come out
tonight and say
gas prices are too high
we need energy Independence and energy
Independence our border is porous and
worse than it's ever been
I want him to come out and say we need
to bring jobs back we need to bring
factories back we need to stop this
military expansion the war in Ukraine is
not America's business
I am that's what I want I want to hear
Maga I want to hear Donald Trump talk
about how he wants to make this country
great I want to hear him tell a story
about a nice family sitting on their
backyard in a rocking chair dad's
reading the paper moms coming out with
some fresh sun tea kids are playing and
he's talking about how the working class
is going to have a better chance at
succeeding in this country
if it is an issue with the ballot
harvesting all that stuff that's a
matter for their strategy to win but not
to win the hearts and minds of the
people to win the election I get I just
kind of feel like if they come out and
they don't talk about issues they're
offering up nothing of substance you
know what I mean look you're talking
you're talking salesmanship instead you
know salesmanship versus statesmanship
right yeah and and you know let's be
honest he could get up there and he
could paint the prettiest of pictures
about what he would intend to do right
the whole
Maga thing right make America great
again but let's be honest at what the
situation is the federal government is
terminally broken right four years
where he was going to drain the swamp
the swamp is deeper than it's ever been
right our lives are still controlled
under 180 000 pages of federal laws
rules and regulations administered by
440 separate agencies and two and a half
million unelected Federal bureaucrats
right the federal debt has gone up to
the point now that our children's
Children's children's children are still
going to be paying on it right so
nothing got done our tax money is being
taken paid to overpaid civil servants
most of them make more than the governor
of our state right where that money in
turn is funneled back into Democratic
coffers that are out there now openly
pushing neo-marx's Theory and philosophy
as public policy the the so he can
promise whatever he wants to promise but
at the end of the day the federal system
anything connected to it is going to be
tainted just like it is and we're we
might as well be Tethered to the Titanic
headed to the bottom of the North
Atlantic I'm curious if he's going to
announce you know two thousand dollar
checks for everyone just like he did 10
grand last time
in all seriousness I would accept if
Donald Trump comes out and says I am
going to be running on one platform
everyone gets fifteen thousand dollars
cash oh so he joined the Yang gang well
Joe Biden came out and offered 10 grand
to everybody in their pocket
unconstitutionally and they they vote
for it oh no so there you go if the
system is going to crumble and fall then
Trump may as well just come out and be
like sure I'll play 15 20 30. why not
50. one word from Trump graphene we're
gonna build the greatest graphene
production facility on Earth the best we
are the best all his friends confused
I've been obsessively telling his
friends when they come here to be on our
show tell Donald Trump graphing this is
it this is the future we become a
graphene industrialist Nation do it
Donald this is your chance and this is
it baby they leave thinking like that's
cool that guy's kind of weird yeah you
gotta be a little more specific we also
have to remember when Donald Trump was
was running uh in 2016 he was promising
a lot of things he was talking about
ending the Federal Reserve he was he was
hinting at 9 11 conspiracies he was
hitting uh you know out of the park when
it came to going at the media one-on-one
is he going to be that same Donald Trump
from two thousand 16 we're going to see
but I think a lot of people want
Solutions not complaining and if he's
going to be complaining he's going to
lose a lot of his base as a lot of
people are already saying hey there's
there's no reason I should be supporting
this because this is not going to help
anyone thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time